uh and i'm going to get the position up
because he deserves to at least have
that final position on the screen
yeah i just want to have it up here for
right
it's a very nice visual all right there
we go
linear dominguez uh you came close
so far in this event to losing round one
winning against fabi but now finally
sealing the deal to go into plus one but
still a lot of work it's not like you're
being handed anything here
yeah it was a very difficult game of
course but uh i was very happy when i
got suddenly chances to win in the night
end game and he blundered king e7 which
was
good for me
but i think yeah overall i was playing
well i was uh
i think i was playing
uh precise and i i just equalized
and i knew i had some chances
potentially because my king is always
very close to the center so he has to be
careful
and
yeah but it should be a draw of course
with correct play but then yeah suddenly
he blundered this king e7 move and then
i get this end game
just uh pawn up and this night end games
of course are
very very uh dangerous when when you're
down material
you
you're now at plus one we've got
somebody at plus two but you're still
chasing you're still tied with a whole
bunch of people sitting a nine plus one
in these kind of long tournaments
what what does it take to win 11
rounders you've been here before after
four rounds
not like anybody saying we're dominating
or clear leaders this early on what does
it take to win
this kind of event yeah i mean you have
to be very consistent um
obviously uh
i think it's i mean at least the way i
do it i just don't um set like a goal
for myself like i'm gonna win or
something i just go game by game
and uh
the thing with this tournament is you
can perform really well you can do
extremely well and still not not not win
the tournament so to win a tournament
you need something special like
circumstances a bit of luck maybe many
things so i think it's just better to
concentrate on on the next game and if
you
do well i mean if i can do well
consistently then i'll get my chances i
remember sam going something like plus
six to confirm what you said and five
you went plus five and and
like i had the magnificent tournament
and didn't do and it didn't do anything
you think anybody's going plus five plus
six given the scores we see now
i mean plus five seems very possible i
don't know about plus six but uh
but yeah it should be should be a tough
fight ahead
all right we know it's time to rest you
get a whole day to do that we'll see you
in a couple of days thank you just a
quick question lanier when you got to
this particular night ending
and you went for
the position with your knight
right here pardon me
you went for the position with your
knight coming to h1
you had anticipated
the sacrifice that we saw in the game
knight takes g3 sacrificing the knight
because that
that was hidden we we were doing it a
different way we were putting our knight
on the f3 square we did not see it first
your idea of knight takes g3 which wins
very very nice that's a that's a
beautiful
night sacrifice it must have felt very
good i i was uh i thought that yeah
there's a few ways to play i could put
my knight on e3 put mine on f3 but i was
i was trying to to fl to find a
clear win and there was actually a nice
line at the end if it takes the knight
i'm sure
you guys saw the line but after king a5
king d5 knight takes g3
if if white takes the knight then d3
knight f1
g3
and now knight e3
and now i cannot play d2 because knight
c4 knight takes d2 and knight of three
so i have to play king a6 here
king king a6 i thought
[Laughter]
wow okay and then after king takes e5
for king or king c4 it doesn't matter i
just go d2 g2 and i i queen
okay
a6 with style yes that would be nice to
win congratulations enjoy your free day
thank you absolutely